what is the absolute value of minus
three the number is minus three it is
represented using vertical bars to the
left and to the right of the number this
thing here is read as the absolute value
of minus three the absolute value of a
number just tells us its distance from
zero on a number line if we have a
number line like this where will minus
three lie it will lie here the absolute
value of minus three is just asking us
how far is minus 3 from zero one two and
three it's three units away from zero
it's simply the distance between minus
three and zero and remember that
distance is never negative we cannot say
that it's minus three units away from
zero as the distance between minus three
and zero is three we say that the
absolute value of minus three is three
what would be the absolute value of
three then the absolute value of three
will be written like this with a
vertical bar to the left and the right
of three how far is three from zero on
the number line again it's three units
away from zero the absolute value of 3
is 3 what will be the absolute value of
-5 as it's five units away from zero it
will be five absolute value of 12 it
will be 12 absolute value of minus 129
it will be 129 look at all the answers
they're all positive so would it be
right to say that the absolute value of
a number is always positive let me ask
you another question that will help you
answer this question what does the
absolute value of zero zero is zero
units away from zero the absolute value
of zero is zero is zero positive no it's
neither positive nor negative
so it would be incorrect to say that the
absolute value of a number is always
positive but you can't say that it will
always be non-negative which means it
will be zero or positive
you